radical republican congresswoman Lauren  bober used to have a restaurant called  Shooter's Grill where people brought  their guns it closed and now it is going  to be replaced by a Mexican restaurant  Lauren bobert used to brag oh it's the  safest restaurant in America because  people bring guns it closed it had such  great dishes as the M16 burrito it was  really a bomb if you can imagine that  anyway it closed and now a Mexican  restaurant is going in it is called  Tapatios Family Mexican restaurant and  uh it sounds really pretty damn good and  the irony of her restaurant being  replaced with that you really can't  write this stuff but I love it